[Music]
Muhammad is depicted in hadiths as
saying, "I looked into paradise and I
saw that the majority of its people were
the poor. And I looked into hell and I
saw that the majority of its people are
women." Now, Muhammad was challenged
about this. He was asked about it and he
explained, "I was shown hell and I've
never seen anything more terrifying than
it. And I saw that the majority of its
people are women." And they said, "Why,
oh messenger of Allah?" He said,
"Because of their ingratitude." And the
word used was kufur, the same word that
is often translated as unbelief. And it
was said, "Are they ungrateful to
Allah?" He said, "They are ungrateful to
their companions, that is their
husbands, and ungrateful for good
treatment. If you are kind to one of
them for a lifetime, then she sees one
undesirable thing in you. She will say,
"I've never had anything good from
you." And in another hadith, Muhammad is
depicted. It says, "The messenger of
Allah went out to the malah, the place
of prayer on the day of Idala or Idel
Fitter, that is the two great feasts,
the great festivals of the Islamic
calendar. He passed by the women and
said, "Oh women, give charity, for I
have seen that you form the majority of
the people of hell." And they asked why
is that, oh messenger of Allah? He
replied, you curse frequently and are
ungrateful to your husbands. I have not
seen anyone more deficient in
intelligence and religious commitment
than you. A cautious, sensible man could
be led astray by some of you. The women
asked, "Oh messenger of Allah, what is
deficient in our intelligence and
religious commitment?" He said, "Is not
the testimony of two women equal to the
testimony of one man?" And they said,
"Yes, because of course that's in the
Quran." He said this is the deficiency
in her intelligence. Then he asked is it
not true that a woman can neither pray
nor fast during her menes and the woman
said yes. He said this is the deficiency
in her religious commitment. Now of
course the absurdity of that is clear.
He made up those laws and then he is
judging women negatively on the basis of
them. Women are essentially slaves of
men in Islam. A hadith depicts Muhammad
saying, "If a husband calls his wife to
his bed, that is to have sexual
relations, and she refuses and causes
him to sleep in anger, then the angels
will curse her till morning." He also
said, "By him in whose hand lies my
life, a woman cannot carry out the right
of her lord till she carries out the
right of her husband. And if he asks her
to surrender herself, that is for sexual
relations, she should not refuse him,
even if she is on a camel's
saddle. For its part, the Quran likens a
woman to a field, tilth, to be used by a
man as he wills. It says, "Your women
are a tilth to you to cultivate. So go
to your tilth as you will." It declares
that a woman's testimony is worth half
that of a man, saying, "Get two
witnesses out of your own men. And if
there are not two men, then a man and
two women, such as you choose for
witnesses, so that if one of them hes
the other can remind her." It allows men
to marry up to four wives and have
sexual relations with slave girls also,
saying, "If you fear that you shall not
be able to deal justly with the orphans,
marry women of your choice, two or three
or four. But if you fear that you shall
not be able to deal justly with them,
then marry only one or take a captive
that your right hands possess that will
be more suitable to prevent you from
doing injustice. The captives of the
right hand are slave girls specifically
for sexual purposes, as the Quran makes
clear in several other passages. The
Quran also rules that a son's
inheritance should be twice the size of
that of a daughter, saying, "Allah
directs you, as regards your children's
inheritance, to the male, a portion
equal to that of two females." Worst of
all, the Quran tells husbands to beat
their disobedient wives. It says, "Men
are in charge of women because Allah has
made the one of them to excel the
other." That is, men are superior to
women. And it goes on to say, "Because
they spend of their property, so good
women are obedient, guarding in secret
that which Allah has guarded. As for
those from whom you fear disobedience,
admonish them, banish them to separate
beds, and beat them." The Quran also
allows for marriage to prepubescent
girls, stipulating that Islamic divorce
procedures shall apply to those who have
not yet menstruated. Clearly, women are
secondass in Islam. chattles of the men
who control them. For more information
about this, see this website.